so I want to introduce you to a concept
known as the sunk cost fallacy imagine
you're going to the store and you're
halfway there when you realize oh wait
the store is actually closed today but
you figure well I've already come ten
blocks I might as well just go all the
way to the store you know so that my ten
blocks of walking won't have been wasted
well this is a transparently silly way
to reason and I doubt that any of us
would actually go all the way to a store
that we knew was closed just because
we'd already gone ten blocks but this
pattern of thinking is actually
surprisingly common in scenarios that
are a little bit less obvious than the
store example say you're in a career and
it's becoming more and more clear to you
that this isn't actually a fulfilling
career for you you'd probably be happier
somewhere else but you figure I'll just
stick with it because I don't want my
past ten years of effort and time and
money to have been wasted so the time
and money and effort and whatever else
you've already spent is what we call the
sunk cost it's gone no matter what you
do going forward and now you're just
trying to decide given that I've already
spent that that money or time or
whatever what choice is going to produce
the best outcome for my future and the
sunk cost fallacy then means making a
choice not based on what outcome you
think is going to be the best going
forward but instead based on a desire
not to see your past investment go to
waste once you start paying attention to
the sunk cost fallacy you'll probably
notice at least a few things that you
would like to be doing differently and
maybe those will be small-scale things
like in my case I now am much more
willing to just abandon a book if 100
pages in I conclude that I'm not
enjoying it and I'm you know not getting
any value out of it rather than trudging
through the remaining 200 300 pages of
the book just because I don't want you
know my past investment of 100 pages the
time that I spent reading those hundred
pages to go to waste and you might
notice some large things too for example
I was in a ph.d program and started
realizing gee this really isn't the
field for me and you know it's a shame
that I have spent the last several years
prepare
for and and working in this ph.d program
but I genuinely predict going forward
that I'd be happier if I switched to
another field and sometimes it really
does take time to fully acknowledge
yourself that you don't have any good
reason to stick with the job or PhD or
project that you've been working on so
long because some costs are painful but
at least having the sunk cost fallacy on
your radar means that you have the
opportunity at least to push past that
and make the choice that instead will
lead to the better outcomes for your
future